I'll never forget our survey Liotta at  the Savannah Film Festival we were down  there and I out auditioned for the part  and Goodfellas I went to Scorsese's  apartment at what apart and I went  auditioned for Scorsese and they got ray  and I saw a ray and we did a movie  together we did this movie with Matthew  Broderick and I said to ray you know ray  a lot of times guys get parts and I go  up four and I don't get the part and I  think to myself I I think I would have  been better in that part I get but  you're the one example of someone I go  that's not true  we're in front of a room full of people  and I go ray I mean no one could have  played that part better than you and he  reaches over any goes I agree so  gracious